hey guys how's it going welcome to tech
Tuesday the tech show where it's never
actually on a Tuesday and if it is
that's a miracle today I'm going to show
you a game called beat sports and this
game is actually played on the new Apple
TV and the difference between the new
Apple TV is not only the new interface
but this new remote control here this is
actually a trackpad now so this allows
you to have more control over your Apple
TV and you can sort of treat it like a
trackpad what's also great about this is
it will allow more functionality for
playing games on your TV through the
Apple TV and the game I'm going to show
you today is called beat sports and beat
sports actually sent me an Apple TV but
I had already bought one so that means I
have an extra Apple TV to give away to
one of you guys if you would like to win
this extra Apple TV that I have please
leave a comment below and say what your
favorite video game is what your
favorite TV show is and why you think
that you shoot the Apple TV
so now as are you guys this game I
started playing it last night and I'm
sure my volume up because this is a
music based game so it's one of the
first games that is built exclusively
for the Apple TV and what's also great
about it is it can play up to four
players so other people who want to play
with you they could just download the
game on their phones and I'll bring that
up here it's also called beat sports but
for the sake of this video we're only
going to show you one player unless I
randomly have some friends come over
which I don't like that's been happening
my dog clearly cannot play this game so
what you do is it's all based off of
timing you play two ways you can swing
the Apple TV remote or you can click
which I think is easier
who's early the first time I tried this
on I wish I would have been filming my
reaction because the music is so funny
like it just thank you thank you very
much thank you I'm gonna play this on a
little bit harder of a level so don't
judge me if I screw up it's a golf club
cuz I don't think it's is that I got I
think you might be a golf club girl is
another one so to scroll over and you
just oute up chip chip you scroll over
with the try the trackpad
okay I've even seen I didn't see the
ball I didn't see the ball you're
cheater you're a cheater
I got one good one it was that last one
so here's the multiplayer options so you
I can just download it which I already
did I clicked it and now would you
showed up it's pretty cool this is great
I'm playing with both know I miss Maddie
what are you bargain about bud yeah
Maddie I'm playing video game honey what
you are you liver of construction people
Maddie what what happened over there
well um he never barks I don't know what
is your problem bud all right
woven ago Maddie it's this funny cuz he
never made yeah well thanks so much for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed this
wonderful tech Tuesday just a quick
little video to show you guys beat
sports and hopefully one of you guys
hold it to win they have on TV let me
know what games you think I should try
out next and I will see you guys in the
next video peace
Maddie look at you look at you you your
wild beast
dies early the first time I chart is on
I wish I would have been filming my
reaction because the music is so funny
like it just sit